In physics, the conservation of energy is highly related to the conservation of area in phase space.
I'm going to introduce that notion in a second.
Solvers did also conserve that area, are pretty good at conserving the energy,
not exactly but almost exactly.
For simplicity, I'm looking at a one dimensional system.
The position is one dimension just a single number,
the velocity has one dimension, just a single number.
Phase space is the coordinate x and v and this is actually use the momentum
which is mass time velocity.
I don't want you to be confused, so I stick to velocity.
For every point in this phase space, you can look it's temporal evolution
given the value of x and given the value of v, we can solve the system of differential equations
and something is going to happen about that point and another point and to another point.
You start from that initial condition to given x and the given v
and look at what happens to this x and that v and look at what happens to position and velocity.
The trick now is to look at infinitely many initial conditions at the same time.
A complete some area in phase space. This is what we're talking about.
Let's look at all of these initial conditions. What's going to happen with them?
Where is the evolution going? Where is the differential equation taking us?
Can this way, we see an evolution of area in phase space?
This set of initial conditions will have to say one second end up here
and after another second may be end up here and so and so on.
An area in phase space remains constant, that's called Liouville's theorem.
Why does the area in phase space stay constant as it evolves? Let's look at the first equation.
The position changes with the rate of the velocity,
so if you rate for a small time and look at wherever ending, x will increase a little here,
increase more here, more here, and so on depending on v
and this motion does not depend on x, it just depends on v.
So, our initial area will be deformed to this which, is the same area.
Simply use this part, glue it to that part and you'll see
that the blue parallelogram has the same area as the top of the rectangle.
So the first equation alone would not change the area.
If you look at the second equation on its own, the rate of change of the velocity
depends on x and on x only, so if this velocity is changed by that much,
also this velocity will change by that much and that velocity will change by that much.
The rate of change does not depend on v, it just depends on x,
so we could have a different rate of change here but it has to be the same for all velocities
and maybe there's a little bit of change here and again it has to be the same for all velocities.
So our purple rectangle is transformed into something that may look like this
and that still has the same area as the original purple rectangle had.
To see that, simply take this slice and push it down and take this slice
and push it down and so on and so on.
So each equation alone would not change the area.
If it continuously apply these rates of change, together we also have no problem.
If x evolve for an infinitesimal short amount of time,
and then we let v evolve for an infinitesimal short amount of time
and then it's the turn of x again and so on and so on--that's going to work.
If we apply the first equation for an infinitesimal amount of time,
and then we apply the second equation for an infinitesimal amount of time,
the area stays the same, and we apply the first equation again and so on and so on.
If you step through this and infinitesimally short time steps, that's going to work.
Problem is can be applied both equations at the same time
and do not use infinitesimally short time steps then it's going to break
and that's precisely what the forward Euler's method does.
You can see one solution to that problem, you apply the first one for a finite time step
then the second one for a finite time step then the first one and second one and so on
one after the other, that's going to work, that's going to conserve a phase space area.
This leads to the conservation of that area and solvers
which have the same property are called symplectic.
Sometimes people also use the term geometric integrators.
We are going to build the simple most one of these and have a look at the long term behavior
and there's something to note all of this works because the force
neither depends on time nor on velocity.
If the force was influenced by time or velocity that would most probably break this nice behavior.
Homework 1 is going to show the evolution of phase space
in action producing some nice diagrams.